[Music]
so if you guys aren't aware this is in
Brazil they're playing funky which is
some
nasty nasty music and uh what do you
mean it's some some very respectable
let me just put it this way the only
thing you're supposed to do when you
listen to this music is your ass
supposed to go up and down
so
anyways all this to say
the artist brings a woman up on stage so
let's keep watching
[Applause]
[Music]
the husband damn right and did you
notice the way the security grabbed him
yeah
because you're not part of the show
[__]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yo they were launching water bottles and
drinks at this man's head for
interrupting the show what I'm not gonna
do is this
I'm not gonna go with my standards and
my other my senators from another
country go judge whatever the hell is
going on in this country all right
I think it's a bit wild but
that's what happens in the country
wait in Brazil you think they let their
wives just go up on stage with a funky
artist to go get dry humped in the air
no sir no sir am I Brazilians watching
right now about to lose their [__]
mind on you think we that degenerate
they do
[Music]
okay listen that's not where I thought
where you and [__] was going to go
inside I'll say this if you my girl if
you're my wife I won't even say a word I
would literally just put the ring down
on the table and bounce yo I mean she
didn't disrespect him once
she didn't disrespect him twice
the [__] disrespected him three times
in the span of two minutes in front of
the worldwide Audis wonder what the
first thing she did getting up on that
[__] station getting dry hung by some
random dude and looking happy but you
want to know the second one he's a
superstar after this dude gets brutal of
State she's seen arguing with him when
he's not upset that's two that's right
number two in public you can't be doing
that after you do some [__] foul [__]
and number three
alone
oh hell no
no sir
hey yo my man said what you think I am
sneako you gonna just cuck me on stage
no bro good for him you have some
self-respect
he saw three pups and he tried to break
that [__] and said [__] what you
[__] doing
you said the three pop [__] yeah he
didn't want to do this
oh yeah
and then one year later becoming Andrew
Tate bot listen all right so boom you
know we're not really bullshitting when
we're doing our thing right so I got
something to show all right I got the
build right here about this thing right
here remember a couple of months back I
received a perfume uh by Sandberg
um this Temple right here loved it see
I'm not kidding you got the those
how about the real thing right here the
big bottle and I was able to do that
with a subscription of Sandberg 17 a
month and I'm able to try different
perfume I don't have to buy the full
thing indeed give a month supply I want
to see what they sent me because they
sent me you know I got a subscription
today we have confession of a rebel
first Trap
by Sicily and we have Skyler Midnight
Moon I'm gonna try them out and I'm
gonna see if I like one and if I do I'm
actually gonna be able to buy the full
thing at the full price instead of
wasting money and time and they have
high-end Brands like Prada Gucci Versace
as well as a variety of high-end
fragrances that you can choose from and
if you click on the link below use the
promo code I've been preach 55 you're
gonna have 55 off your first month
yeah on us I'm watching this thing and
all I can think of is how quickly but I
wouldn't have to worry about something
like this because nobody I've ever been
with ever do something about
disrespectful you gotta think like
her doing that means she don't really
see you as anything but to begin with OR
she doesn't even know your boundaries
which it's like you have to have some
common sense
you know what I mean like I don't think
it's something I should have to explain
to my partner
I just don't I don't think that's
something I would have to explain to my
partner since my partner to do something
like that I'm like I don't know that's
crazy you know what else you know what
this was what that was that girl that
went on spring break but life in his
face yeah that's what it that's what it
was yeah because let me ask you okay
let's say you had to put your old life
savings on if her husband wasn't there
and that artist said would go come
backstage
what you putting your money off I'm not
saying what she would have done 100 I'm
just saying if you have to put your
entire life savings never mind some of
you [__] got zero dollars if I gave
you 20 G's to put in your life savings
and you gotta you gotta bet okay
what are we batting on who's coming
first also my bad I know I know some of
y'all whatever who's coming first
what oh cause she's going there that's a
fact so what are we betting on who's
coming first you think she's going
backstage no I don't know are we betting
on the fact that she's coming first or
he's coming first okay so you think they
smash you for sure that's that's a given
the way you gave that 20 G just because
she liked to go out and dance with her
girls only she want to get freaky freaky
some girls just want a good night
a great night
a really good night last night was a
really bad night
fine midnight throw me six so let me go
in back midnight last night oh that's
here yes
I Was Fear last night
that [__] always be playing in my car
that's why you think yeah yeah that
should be making me wanna
pause
that's the end of this video no that's
because you went no listen look at that
dumb little smile
hey hey yo leave a comment for that hey
yo you
I have my past moments you just had your
big one because I didn't have one in a
while I have to like poof oh my God you
that's because you always give it off a
little bit of positive energy no never
never okay anyways what do you think
about this topic
she's [__] if this guy is not there
Bianca hit is just [__] what do you
think about the whole thing no of course
like what I said was what I said it was
like just a joke and everything and
stuff but no of course I understand the
guy acting like that that's crazy
everybody sees it and it's probably like
in a town everybody knows each other
they know who the [__] some of y'all
some of these [__] know the
[__] you are you understand what I'm
saying so it's like you know whenever
you talk to talk about yo who would you
give a free pass to like who who if I
give you a free pass who would you smash
a game that I would never play with my
girl and I never played and I would
never play with my significant other
like I don't want to know and you don't
want to know right because it's all cute
and everything and stuff when it's a
celebrity but the minute I say yo friend
you're gonna be like what and there's
gonna be a problem so I ain't saying
[__] and I'm not playing that game
anyways
[Music]
that's being said uh yeah she went live
and just went that's crazy it's all fun
and games until it happens for real true
that's a lot anyways
that's pretty much some of my thoughts
what do you guys think what would you
guys do in that situation let us know in
the comments below we want to hear from
you Sandberg click on the link below and
you're going to be able to save 55 off
your first month get your smell on you
know that's the key to get the ladies
all right